we're going to be watching the dying
light 2 stream from techland i don't
know how long this is going to be
um i suspect we're probably not going to
get like a whole conference length of
information but
uh anyone who's been following the
channel for a while would know that i've
been very excited about dying light too
um i've had like some concerns about the
game being delayed
i saw gameplay so long ago it feels like
a whole lifetime ago
uh so that's definitely a factor
obviously they
lost some major staff and had some
internal things going on
um but uh still really excited to learn
more about it
in part because the tech of this one in
particular really gets me so
yeah i thought that i would stream it it
is generally my start time around now
anyway it is 5 am which is when i start
work so it is pitch black outside still
um it's basically my morning but it's
probably not the case for most of you
so let's do it we have 30 seconds on my
countdown
well you guys are all seeing the same
thing aren't you
yeah i really loved the first game and
uh this one seems like it's
experimenting with with
some tech i'm really interested in so
hopefully we get to see some of that the
last update i was like please give us a
little bit more information also i'm
just going to turn
the audio up a little bit just in case
maybe there
you guys please let me know if it needs
to change when the conference starts in
three seconds
or stream i don't know
[Laughter]
okay let's go
[Music]
into it so far
hello guys nice to meet you g'day mate
i'm leah and this
is dying to know if you're dying to know
what's going on in the world of dying
light too then
you're in the right good thank you
the latest from the dying light world
we'll be announcing a few contests we'll
be talking to developers
and probably most importantly they're
going to be showing you a brand new
gameplay trailer where you can see the
characters call it of the dying light 2
game
but first this
i'm a pilgrim an outcast
roaming like a japanese ronan or an old
west desperado
my past is dark but my future
has a tiny dying light at the end of
this time
um guys my name is jonas scott and i
voice aiden caldwell and dying light too
but
before that i'm gonna host this program
with leia
if you don't mind my pleasure well i'm
ready
jonah's definitely ready and i hope that
was cool
so if you're dying to know just like us
stick with us
uh yeah chat so you know there's almost
a minute delay so if you spam stuff
like you did with the audio i had fixed
it already please come back
and if you're wondering what happened in
those intervening 20 years well there's
no better person to ask than the dying
lights you
world director over the in just a moment
and after that i'll be speaking with
pietz germanic the narrative director of
the game
so about the characters that appear in
dying light too
so i really like the presentation
welcome to the show thomas so the first
question
i would like to see the game do i need
to have played dying light one to sort
of understand what's happening in
dynamite ii
no actually you don't uh like you
mentioned before a game takes place some
20 years later
you know where humankind has lost the
water to the virus so
in a way you could say that dying there
too takes us to the world beyond the
apocalypse
intriguing all right tell me more please
well you remember the events of heron in
2014
well after that world leaders they had a
tough choice to make
they had to isolate the city of heron
right for that they created an exclusion
zone
like in chernobyl only a lot more people
were left to die inside the walls
yeah right so they just isolated the
entire classic big
big copper am i right okay
forget about it at least it is a really
cool secret
scientists continue to study the virus
you know manipulating his dna creating
new strains
they were looking for commercial
military applications so you know
they're
doing it for the money really yeah of
course so what happened next
well next the [ __ ] hit the fan by
christmas 2021 one of these mutated
strains i assume that we'll learn all of
this from the level
when playing the game so i'm i'm not i
don't really know if this i don't super
urgently feel like i even want this
information right now this time the
virus was much faster
i appreciate it but also before the
world could react civilization was on
the brink of collapse
people were dying in the streets capital
cities were burning
by the end of 2023 98 percent of the
population had been lost to the virus
how much of the sense is cgi it would be
majority of the fact one city
screened the last bastion of mankind the
stuff in front of the city
the door is real the city right right so
villadore is what we have
left so that's everything that's
happened outside of the city
what actually happens inside
philadelphia well the city has
unique rules first of all it's
surrounded by uh seemingly impassable
walls
and inside the walls of the people that
decided to use seemingly impossible
against
protection interesting choices in the
first stages of the pandemic
but it also created terrifying new
monsters oh cool
15 years on a new equilibrium sort of
emerged in the city
by daylight human factions fight to
control the city and at night the
streets become the wrong that is the
thing that i'm very interested about
what this gameplay wise is though um
that is
extremely interesting and that seems
like a weird thing to say but more about
the vibrant and
it seems like which one i hope but first
i think we need to hear a little bit
more about the characters
sure it seems like which one you you
align with will visually change the city
which
is a second guest he's a man of two
industries cinema
and gaming in a previous life he wrote
the hit hbo series
um and then he moved on to tech land to
become a narrative director
germanic hi guys thank you so uh we have
plenty of time to talk about the rest of
the characters and dying lights
there there are tons of them but today i
think we want to focus on aiden caldwell
the protagonist do you want to talk
more about them or yeah sure
no i'm good actually a group of people
traveling through this dangerous like
dying light too
called pilgrims because he's looking for
his relative
the person whom he lost many many years
ago
and that person is his only memory from
the past
and the only answer to whom aiden really
is
aiden is a really rich deep character
very very much cooler than i am
i mean he can run across buildings jump
from rooftop to rooftop use all kinds of
weapons
yeah well you know if he didn't have
much choice this world is
full of infected bloodthirsty creatures
so he didn't have much choice right
the weak guy the strong survive and i
didn't he just
has to be strong i'd be dead but
fantastic why why he that's the
main question of the game and the player
will have
opportunity also to decide how aiden
will evolve will he
help the weak will it distract him from
his main goal
or maybe he will just strive to the end
of his search as soon as possible i
can't imagine trying to survive
or live in a city like that as a lone
wolf by yourself
without any kind of support this is like
great production value but so far it's
just not a ton of stuff
or that i think i will be interested in
learning when i play it and not now
it's gotta be hard to do this some of
them will become his
enemies one of the groups he will
encounter are the night runners
the former special force officers who
were sick of
the army's cynicism and lack of concern
for
common people but they were brave enough
to help the people during the night and
the night
as you know is pretty horrifying in the
game yeah so
you don't know things get really hard in
the game oh that's
nice at least the player will have to
answer too
spoil the pleasure of discovering
aidan's actions and true motivations
but what i can share with you is uh the
fact that we
really put big effort to make this
character and many others
complex and multi-dimensional but there
is so much more to be discovered
protagonist in the first game
i liked him thank you um
but he was pretty standard that's what i
was saying he was like the game plan
he's kind of
kind of a guy doing stuff you need to
talk about something
which is basically the center of the
dying light universe is the release date
the community oh over the past few years
dying light has amassed over 23 million
players
and a 95 positive review rating on steam
twitch in steam talk is overwhelmingly
positive so profit
we'd like to take a few seconds and
thank you guys thank you all for being
on this journey with us thank you for
sharing your love with others of dying
light
and thank you for these great moments
spent together
and thank you for the gameplay dying
light one has some amazingly creative
sounds which
is probably not going to be very much i
also wonder if we'll get a release we're
going to be starting a brand
new contest which will combine your love
of dying light with that same creativity
with the release date of dying light 2
drawing ever closer we'd like to extend
our hand and invite you to make the
community a little bit bigger
if you find yourself skilled in the ways
of visual arts writing or costumes and
cosplay please
join the dying light universe so check
out dying light game dot com
forward slash contest and if you win
there's a fantastic monetary prize on
the line listen
also there's some other great rewards
that makes me think the game is coming
out this year
platinum edition of dying life why are
you trying to get people to post stuff
they've made if it's not coming out this
year you know what i'm saying
this is the finest edition of dying
light ever made this is the platinum
edition
of dying light this has every bit of
content ever released for dying
it's a really good game honestly if
you've not played it i think it would
still hold up me i
played it when it came if you haven't
experienced dying light yet we are
introducing dying light one platinum
edition but there is also one
biggest complete addition to ever
standalone which was also offering it to
you now
at an historically low price all the
content
lowest price it's literally no better
time to buy than now and you can get it
on steam
xbox and playstation get your platinum
edition of dying light
now this is the best offer like ever
i guess we don't have time to go over
everything that's in the platinum
edition but
it is everything i thought he was going
to say everything but his gameplay
and also the release date again really
well produced
great looking conference but i don't
feel like it's necessarily actually been
much information
which is like maybe this is what they or
did they pat it because they
wanted it to be longer than the last one
so it feels more substantial than their
last update which was like only a couple
minutes long and so they were
criticizing for it
or uh
was that what people were asking about
i'm not sure
this is platinum edition by the way it's
[Music]
not
[Music]
i am dying i'm excited because you guys
are in just a second
gonna see the official gameplay trailer
for dying light 2 and then after that
we're going to interview some of the
devs that made it possible cool
so without further ado here it is
hey everyone i'd like to see it we've
been quiet for some time
since like the rest of the world we had
some unforeseen hurdles to clear
but the wait is over
let's dive into the open world of dying
light ii
was that scripted because that was a
cinematic
does that happen every time dying like
to showcase the mission from the main
storyline
you get after those [ __ ] yeah i went and
saw it
this time we want to give you a broader
look at the game and a sneak peek at
some of the things we'll be talking
about
i mean that looks stunning
in dying light ii you become aidan
caldwell an outsider trying to unravel a
tangled mystery from his past
its trail leads him to the city probably
the last bastion of mankind in the world
[Music]
at first you feel like this intense
brutal place will tear
you off the lighting is then you meet
the night runners you don't have to
country survivors who help people in
better days
by the way i'm hate gun you were a night
runner
you used to help people remember my
runners are gone
finished a myth
and although it's not entirely clear you
can trust them
you need allies in the dark
i'm totally getting lost in those pipes
obviously there's a lot of overlap that
that's unavoidable
and these are the modern darts i've seen
it's been 15 years
with your buds since the last of us has
changed
the old civilization has fallen but a
new one
has been built on its ashes
[Music]
people fight desperately for scarce
resources
rules are broken and weakness is
punished
survivors pride themselves on being able
to adapt
in circumstances again almost everywhere
peacekeepers loyal soldiers who want to
impose their version of law and order
and trampoline i
just think the um well designs
ex-prisoners serving their ruthless
colonel
seeking to become a strange way to put
that but that is what i mean
use these factions to reach your goal
help or harm them to reshape the city to
your liking
just remember each faction contains
complex characters
nosey parker ain't you got some kind of
bad habit of yours
faces look pretty good too i follow cold
calculations but whatever you know i
don't or your heart
try to pay too much attention to
graphics help us and you'll find a home
here
some in the city offer no chance for an
alliance bandits
outlaws and common thugs live only to
plunder and kill
plunging the streets into chaos
those humans yeah nightfall
scares all of them equally
i think that that's really neat it's a
cool invention
darkness changes the rules of the world
as the light fails the monsters crawl
out of hiding to prey on the
poor souls caught outside the safety of
uv
rays hordes of infected pour into the
streets like decaying lava
the deadly spawn of 15 years of mutation
and evolution
[Applause]
oh wow
what that mouth do your only escape
exploit the city's verticality and flee
to the roofs
even there you are never safe from swift
and deadly virals
[Applause]
greater honestly this part of dying
light is so fun like it's so much fun
oh my god and the thing about the night
time is
the first time you do it as well
terrified nests rife with infected
during the day
now lie empty
to explore them you must tread carefully
that's interesting
but those brave enough to face the
terrors of the night can loot
a jackpot all right
what's going on here
pregnant success
luckily you have all the tools you need
to survive
yeah running on walls allow you to
navigate even the most treacherous
terrain
i'm glad video games exist because never
in a million years would i be willing to
do this mirror's ed
[ __ ] you can count on your partner
acrobatics to save your life cool
but often you'll have to face your
enemies head on and then you have to be
smart
resourceful
and get shot
[Music]
we've worked hard on the essence of our
combat oh you think it was an antisyn
injection yes that makes sense i assumed
it was help
well executed but
even the most brutal fights can be
tactical as well
you have multiple ways to hone your
skills toward the gameplay style that
suits you best
it's up to you if you focus mostly on
mobility and parkour
your aggressive blunt force combat or
a crafty approach where the tools you've
created get the job done
i think that's what i'll go ahead and
learn can be a game changer and possibly
a new favorite move
the game did get really hard in the
latter stages against the humans so i
remember it
things move escalated pretty
significantly it was fun
in a good way each move could mean
triumph or
defeat i'm watching you
choose your actions and friends what you
thought [ __ ] everything can do in the
city can reshape the gameplay
environment
change the course of the narrative and
decide the fate of the cities
what i'm excited about but most
importantly
you decide you're on fate as well you're
about to turn
make sure it looks like little fingers
human
oh okay confirmed it is the injection
was going to be something
you could uh give yourself to stop an
extensive
world i really like that divisiveness
you know the uh life on the roof and
then and then death on the streets yeah
like the
intensity of the day and the night cycle
together
yeah it's almost like dying like two is
two different games put together into
one yeah like despite that despite all
the brutality going on on the ground
floor there's something about like the
rooftops and the plants
it's cozy yeah i kind of kind of want to
be there
but it does feel like every decision is
vital like your choices actually do have
some consequences choices and
consequences are incredibly vital to
dying light 2's gameplay and we're going
to interview some devs and talk about
some other very vital gameplay looks
awesome i know we can't wait to get our
hands on it but congrats
yeah for sure it looks like you guys
have a very unique world and a very
unique game where y'all get your
inspiration from
oh that was a research we did a deep
dive into the history of our work and we
found repetitive patterns we found that
people use the same behaviors
in the past after the fall of
civilization or after the fall
of the nation that's supposed to be a
backbone of our worth
so our approach was super simple we just
copycat those behaviors
and attitudes and show you how
our world would look like after not
uncommon however it's uh it's kind of
obvious that the main reason that
civilization
flow is 5 19 or eventually the
economy will collapse yeah that's that's
basically obvious thing
but it's even darker if you connect
those things with the research with it
in at the beginning of the production so
people will
question everything they're gonna blame
everything and everyone that's supposed
to guide us
in our lives every day so they're gonna
play governments they're gonna play
low they're gonna blame science or even
religion it's a great accent some people
might
might ask themselves that where was god
when
it happened to us basically you know so
i feel that all of those things together
creates the
sensation that it's a giant step
backward for our civilization
so dying light too has a subtitle stay
human what does that mean well it's it's
super hard to
to remember those values that makes us
human so like
compassion or or support so the entire
fall that those dark times we have is
that is a big test for
for everyone and i think it's even
harder tests
because to stay human people would
sacrifice
what's the most important for them or
sometimes risk their lives wow so that's
like
really intense and there's like the
obvious like double
meaning to it which is what i was
thinking stay human don't become
a zombie yeah but one this time those
are not zombies
those are infected people that turn to
be a monster
yes crossing a line you know and they're
turning to be a
monster you know because in diagram we
all infected
yeah we all wearing this biomarker you
know it and you're wearing this i'm
wearing this
that's a watch actually you know that
you know so that's uh
does i think so that the challenge is to
not cross this line at all costs so
that's
the biggest challenge i do find that
kind of mechanically interesting like in
the original dead rising
i think they might have all done
thank you so much adrian we're
definitely gonna be hearing from you
again soon yeah thank you so much yeah
they all did it they did it more than
just the first one the first one i feel
like was just really aggressive about it
it's like
making sure that you guys
are make sure you accomplish this task
before this timer goes off
um i like that struggle i like the
struggle of like i need a purge making
sure i have this thing that makes me
not turn into a hospital and they have
to experience or endure
like the pressure basically the whole
system of choice and consequences is
really really complex that's what i'm
here for let's do it
i would say the best way to describe it
is that player is making the decisions
based on three layers first one are the
choices that you do
during the main story missions and
though those big changes are actually
can change the whole game
or even how the story ends the second
layer are choices where
that you do while the quests and those
choices can actually
influence the mission itself the last
one the last layer is so-called
city alignment that's what i'm and i is
open world game designer
would like to focus on great go on all
right so
water and electricity are basically a
key to survive in every word
by restoring it player cannot not only
unlock the water or electricity in the
area
but he can also based on his decision
assign it to one of the factions
which will influence how the district
looks like or who's going to live inside
it might be minor but it is the
beginning of something pretty more
important for a player really i think a
lot of games are going to
try to do this going forward like unique
tools for inspections
like car traps zip lines or trampoline
that player can
use an exploration to deal with bandits
or like i am
infected positive this is what faster
than the system that is like this but
way more extensive probably is what ken
levine based on your
choices you shape the game environment
which gives you a really different
experience every time
and what it's worth mentioning here that
timeline ii
is playable up to four call players so
you can host the game or join other
players
and see how their choices came up
differently to your own
right interesting there's one thing i'm
really curious about though
uh night versus day how does the game
play differ
from the night and the day well the
short answer is that
day is for humans and night is for the
monsters
but to describe it a little bit better i
would say that during the day
humans in factions bandits or
survivors scavenging the city or
humanitarian evidence or some scraps
or someone who might have them and this
is the best time for a player to
explore the city meet its citizens
learn the stories day-to-day agenda or
even simply help them in a question i do
repeat that this is pretty cheesy
dark ages yeah and that sounds quite
pleasant but not too easy to watch
night changes everything exactly it just
feels very scripted but also infected
get out of the building they keep
mistakes which is a strange choice the
knight is going to be even more intense
this time
cool intense in terms of the amount of
enemies
the new types and new more aggressive
behaviors
and what is important this time night
can be also an
opportunity an opportunity for the
players who are
carriage and skilled enough to use the
fact that all the infected
are outside we have already been over
this buildings are accessible
to explore them and search but i
appreciate you saying it and you're
fantastic
you're responsible for the
post-apocalyptic look of the city
can you tell us a little bit how about
the city became to look that way
yes i guess the important thing to
realize is in 2025 a
decision was made to use a chemical
attack
to stop the spread of the haran virus
and the result
is a tight ring of chemically active
areas around the city
that some of the chemicals have gotten
into the groundwater
and spread under the surface that's not
great every living plan
but usually it will be quite interesting
what it means for the city
the street levels are virtually dead
the soil is unable to sustain any life
any plant and the street level is a
domain it really should feel lighted
just if they do it right every aspect
that dead layer on the bottom
it's just no life scene okay quite far
up
on the top from where the humans are
surviving on the street level is pretty
tough
so the common people created are just
visitors there
but the life prevailed it moved up to
the rooftops
and this is where where the plants are
flourishing
and blooming and the and it's cool
post-apocalyptic landscape and this is
where people
build and develop the the new world of
dying light to
uh yeah the stuff being on the roof
system windmills and safe zones for the
player
and in a way in a metaphorical sense the
rooftops are the new default
ground floor the level zero and trip to
the
streets is in a way a trip on the ground
a minus one
of swords just the corpse of uh
of a lost civilization wow
yeah to say the least i can't imagine
being a citizen living in that
that city let alone being a player and
how how challenging that's gonna be
yeah and hold that thought thank you
very much for joining us today uh but
it's now time
to introduce our next guest does make me
excited to see more so they've done
their job
well i guess with us now are bartosz
and peter and guys i have one question
about the open world and dying like two
how big is it
it's pretty big we know that can you
tell us a little bit more
yes of course the map in dying light ii
is divided into two huge regions and
several zones
there are plenty left overs from the
lost civilization for you to scuba but
we didn't want uh
our players to perceive the map only
horrible very cool set
it's distracting we see them as a
multi-level 3d world
that supports your traversal and helps
you solve parkour puzzles
yes in house we're calling multi-layer
open war exploration
and you know the movement system from
dike light 1
we remove every restriction from the
player you can move everywhere you want
how you want to do it and when i think
about it i think that was
big challenge for us to create the
geometric that support all of that
and we did it and i think we did it well
doing the same thing
in dying light 2 wasn't our goal we want
to make
one or more step forward to suppress the
player expectation
that's why we doubled the number of
pokemons doubled
that's very cool and i mean it's not
like there was a shortage in timeline
so what yes the iconic dank light juan
parker
is essential that's awesome we improve
it we double the number of parkour moves
the players will see over three thousand
oh my god
i'm glad they're not saying like we
rebuilt it from the ground up because it
was already very good
so i like the language that you can see
we made it more free we added three
thousand
animations that rules because in the
next episode we're going to be talking
more about parkour and how
so they are going forward authentic
night city wire reports seriously
thank you guys so much for the
information box peter it's been a
pleasure thank you
thank you very much so there will be
more no release date
today okay so the last and arguably the
most important question i'm sure you
have is
when is the release date yeah that is a
very very very very important question
and luckily we have the answer and the
answer is
the 7th of december checks out waited
years to say that out loud awesome
and now that we know the release date of
the game it's time for you my head
immediately went
subject to delay i don't know we'll see
i don't know why i feel like this one's
gonna get delayed pre-order but
exciting congratulations you just
pre-ordered one of the most anticipated
games of this year
go you i mean i'm definitely gonna play
this game there's no question i'm i am
really
definitely looking forward to it oh wow
i want one well i do have an eight inch
figure that i got an e3
two years ago part of the collector's
edition of dying light too
and you can get one for yourself if you
want uh we'll leave like a property i
love the ub stuff that's neat
for the professionals but we do have it
all in front of us right now so
it'd be rude not to take a look uh you
get in the collector's edition
a concept art book full of stunning
artwork from the game
you get this steel book which will have
your game inside it of course
and you get this uh interesting little
uv flashlight so
yeah cool looks like there's all sorts
of vanity elements in here too like some
legendary skin packs
as well as all sorts of digital elements
for more information on these digital
elements
uh please visit the pre-order website as
opposed to
skin packs were not included if you're
feeling the same way then
i've got good news because you can
pre-order the collector's edition
however it is very very limited so
you'll have to be very quick
rest assured there will be plenty of the
standard edition for your standard gamer
but if you're into special editions
there is a deluxe edition of dying light
2 with a steel book
legendary pack and a digital soundtrack
and much much more
so to summarize that's three different
editions that you can buy depending on
what you're after
and if you just can't wait until release
to get immersed in the world of dying
light too
then why don't you go check out the
technon gamers on goodies
then why don't you play this demo dammit
whether or not you want updates on dying
like
the news or you want dying light 2 items
in dying light 1.
everyone's going to find something they
like there yep and this is just an
initial offering as well
check back later for even more details
more information and we'll be going
through it in future episodes as well
that's it don't forget to pre-order the
game and take part in our contests
the details are on the game's website i
feel like it was pretty good overall
sneak peek at the topic of the next
episode
thank you for watching and stay safe out
there bye see ya
i have no qualms with tuning into more
of these
that said i don't feel like i need to
know anymore at this point i do feel
like i'm like
i'm at the point of information where
i'm like i'm good i'm gonna buy this
game you don't need to tell me anymore
what does it say
oh just stay tuned um
but you know for coverage purposes i
might stream some more of these uh that
was fun
um yeah some some repetition in the
information there but
i'm alright with it i i think the game
looks awesome
i'm still really excited about it um
yes there was gameplay sorry if you
missed it
and uh yeah i hope that it's all that it
seems like it is
um but otherwise everybody i have to
head off
we will be live again for horizon today
i'm basically making these my lunch
breaks because this one
like i said went longer than i expected
so i'm gonna split my lunch break up
into two
to get through this for the day so yes
um we'll be back here at
7 a.m australian eastern standard time 2
p.m pacific time i think for
the horizon um to see gameplay from the
state of place and i'm very excited
about that
but uh yeah thank you all for joining me
here today i appreciate it
and i will see you a little bit later
bye